The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: I should
thank Kevin Lynch.
37 years ago, he stopped
me in the corridor.
I was teaching in
the design program,
and that was before we
had a separate section
for architecture and urbanism.
And he said, you know, I'm going
to stop teaching this class.
He had already
taught it since 1956.
I said, why?
It's an important class.
It's the only place where people
learn about the form of cities
in a systematic way.
And he said, no, the
students are bored by it.
There's just a
lapse in interest.
So I said, are you crazy.
He said, OK, well, you're
interested in theory,
aren't you?
And I said, well, I am not sure.
He said--
[LAUGHTER]
--I'll make a deal with you.
If you teach it with me for
the next period, I'll continue.
So we taught it
together for two years,
and he just announced
that he's retiring,
leaving the whole
damn thing to me.
That was 34 years ago.
I have to thank him for
giving me the opportunity.
Curiously enough,
Kevin and I have now
taught this class from 1956 to
2013, which is a long stretch.
Neither of us will have
any formal education
in urban history.
We don't teach urban
history formally.
You can do a degree
in city planning
without knowing
where Priene was.
It said neither
Harvard nor MIT have
treated urban history with
the dignity that it deserves.
We had an alphabet,
but I suppose
seeing that Lynch and I--
you will see here as I
go through this class--
how much history there is in it.
It's not history for
the sake of history.
It's based on a fundamental
idea that accumulated knowledge
makes sense critically.
The modern movement
in architecture
abjured the notion of
looking at the past.
They were so
existentially bound up
with the present, nor the
future, for that matter--
I'll be covering some of this.
I'm just digressing warming up.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a class tradition
to do the last class.
I'm not doing the last
class because it's
the last class for me.
I'm doing the last class as I've
always done it for 34 years.
That is, it's an
attempt to summarize
the material we've done.
And as difficult as
that is, I'm going
to go through it tediously.
I hope those of you who've
taken this class will forgive me
for going over what
you already know.
There are two things that
I learned from Lynch.
The one is that when you
posit an idea or theory,
theory is perhaps
an overblown word.
I inherited the title
of this class from him
and never changed it.
You have to, where possible,
supplement it with a fact.
If you go down the corridor
to Lynch's archives,
you'll find his high school
notes on Kant and philosophers.
We always thought that
if we were teaching
this class in France,
we would never
provide any evidence
for the theory
and just produce more theories
based on the theories that
preceded us.
So I have the Chicago
tradition to follow,
which says that you
have facts to supplement
theory-- a very American
idea, if I might say so.
The second thing is that
details are important.
So when I tell you that
Joseph Bazalgette used
300 million bricks to build
the three cross London sewage
tunnels because of
cholera in the Thames,
you will understand 300
million is a useful figure--
for some people anyway.
The last thing that
Lynch tried to argue
was that, difficult though
it is to find evidence,
the easy relationship
between space and society,
and even if you had
to make blind cases,
it was better than
nothing at all.
So, for instance, I argue that
the invention in Birmingham
in 1830 of the mortgage
system had profound effects
on British home ownership.
The United States
lagged behind, and there
are reasons to
believe that the Great
Depression in this country was
the cause of there only being
balloon or standard loans.
The mortgage system
provides security,
and in the absence of
curious crooked landlords,
you dealt with a bank,
which provided security,
as microfinancing
in the Third World
is now providing security
for home ownership
to people who've lived
in insecure situations
all their life.
But I can't argue that whilst I
guess that the mortgage system
reduced the density of London
by spreading it out as opposed
to Paris, which didn't--
the density of Paris
is about twice as much
as that of London--
but I have to guess that
the mortgage system has
something to do with it.
There are not many
people who attempt
the steering business of
connecting space and society.
I one edited an Italian
version of a magazine
by their name
[SPEAKING ITALIAN],,
so I guess I've
spent my life trying
to understand the relationship.
And I'm not sure after 34 years
of slogging away in this room
that I'm any clearer.
So what I'm going to do
is go through the material
we've done in this class.
I'll try to be as
brief as possible.
If you get bored, I
can't offer you a drink.
You have to wait.
I'll try to make
as many connections
as I can in the
material, but I'm
going to go through it as if
I'm talking to this class, some
of whom are here, and
they are the only ones who
are allowed to ask questions.
The rest of you
are in a time warp.
[LAUGHTER]
Remind me of that movie--
I can't remember
the title-- where
the time was changed, where
the past became the present.
It's very strange
to see all of you.
We start at the beginning.
About 1,000 miles from where
I was born, archaeologists,
such as [? Broome, ?]
Dart, and Tobias,
discovered a
3-million-year-old skull,
which they called
Australopithecus africanus,
a fundamental link
between animal and man.
The brain size of
Australopithecus
was about 400 cubic
centimeters, about 35%
of our contemporary brain size.
The argument is that the
increase of brain size
is largely due to nutritional
change, such as Leakey's
first discovery of
the first [? index ?]
in the Olduvai Gorge in
Kenya, which dates back
to about 2.6 million years.
Nutrition, and a little change,
is argued as fundamental
to brain increase.
I don't know how much larger
the human brain can become
seeing we still
reproduce children
through female organs, which
are not infinite in size,
though some people
would wish they were.
I've often wondered when the
first item for storage of food
occurred.
I think potter's wheels
must come very early.
I can't imagine any other
permanent form of change
in nutrition.
But the British
anthropologist Robin Dunbar
hypothesizes that human
brains grew faster
when surrounded by 150
others, a number he still
holds true for modern societies,
even in social media groups.
You're supposed to
know only 150 people.
His argument is that
brain size increases
when you're in a society.
It's fundamental to the
premise of the city.
He goes on to even insinuate
that gossip or grooming
of newcomers requires
language, and language
comes from that need
rather than any other.
It's often been assumed
the language derives
from men hunting.
I use this beginning to
indicate the importance
of the educative potential
of the social city.
And secondly, despite all
the talk about the city,
it's still in its
relative infancy,
at most 10,000 years in
about 3 million years
of human development.
We've only been going
for 10,000 years at most.
It's nothing.
It took us 3 million
years to get a big brain,
and we've wasted it over
the last 10,000 years.
It says that those of you who
are going to be graduating
still have a chance to improve.
Your brain's not going
to get any larger,
but your capacity in
the use will increase.
From there, we switch to Kevin's
three theories of city form.
The first is the so-called
cosmic view of the city.
According to
[INAUDIBLE],, archaic city
form had to do
with centeredness,
the celestial system,
ritual, and circular time.
The earliest cities were
religious in nature and form,
superintended over be
omnipotent priests,
who secluded their
treasure in secret
in remote holy of holies,
such as the Temple of Marduk
on the 200-foot high
tower of Babel in Babylon.
The Tower of Babel is
at its extreme height
for a compression structure
without independent support.
And you put the temple of
the city at the top of it,
as you do in--
I did a small case of Jerusalem
to make an important point.
I was fortunate to
work in Jerusalem,
both for the Palestinians
and the Israelis,
and had the chance to
autodidact a lot of its history.
Solomon built the first temple
in Jerusalem in 1,000 BC,
a typical compression
fortress with remote sanctuary
and no public access.
Sacrifice is part of the ritual.
In the 7th, 6th
century BC, the temple
is destroyed by
Nebuchadnezzar, and the Jews
are taken into exile in Babylon,
the greatest city on Earth.
There they, deprived
of a temple,
turn to pray in homes,
schools, et cetera.
Despite having the
prophet Ezekiel
with them, which covers six
chapters in the Old Testament
detailing measures of
an envisioned temple,
they learn not to miss
the temple any longer.
They invent a new form
of democratic religion.
What the relationship is
between deprival and innovation
in cities is an
interesting idea.
It's sometimes justifies,
in theorists' minds,
the notion that people
should be deprived.
When I showed my work in
Johannesburg in London
at the ICA one day
a long time ago,
I showed the [INAUDIBLE]
Township wall paintings.
And a man in the audience
stood up and said,
if I were in Germany, would I
be collecting Jewish scribbles
on walls?
I'd always seen the anarchistic
reaction to survival
as an important fundamental
human condition.
He was turning it
around and saying,
one shouldn't
record the blemishes
of the past which have
succeeded in providing
an avenue for improvement.
Anyway, back to Johannesburg.
The Jews returned from Babylon
to Jerusalem, and Ezra--
the same name of my
grandson, not he--
read the Bible, and
the people wept.
Towards the end
of the millennium,
Herod rebuilds the temple.
Now priests, under the
embodiment of the threat
to the priests in Germany
because the synagogue
is appearing and democratic
religion is becoming
an argument--
before he dies, Christ
appears as a radical threat.
He is the embodiment
of the threat
to the priests in Germany.
In his famous statement in the
forecourt of Herod's Temple,
after years harassed
the merchants,
he says, "Soon the
temple will be destroyed.
Don't despair.
From then on, my body
will be your temple."
Here is a form of substitution,
from autocracy to democracy.
This is the origin
of the church,
the origin of the mosque,
the origin of the synagogue,
the origin of any form
of communal prayer--
at least in my view it is.
I, therefore, not
as a Christian,
do not think Christ's death
is terribly important.
It's only important
as a major transition
from the archaic
state of the world
to a beginning of a
new communal democracy,
at least in religion,
not in society.
70 years later, the Romans
destroyed the temple,
and the Jews had a temple again.
The Jews lived in diaspora
with their synagogue and book,
the Christians with the
celebration of Christ's body.
The Catholic church
still, in miraculous ways,
uses the mass to
celebrate Christ's body.
And my argument is that
it comes from this time.
I'm not a Christian, so I can
be scatological about religion.
I keep on being that way.
Nothing convinces me.
Nobody uses this argument in
the literature that I read,
because it's also theocratically
ordered that it can't--
this is a classic
case in which nobody's
making the radical argument
that the Son of God
can, in fact, change
an important function
in the world.
We briefly discus the cosmic
idea in China and India.
We also point to the wide use of
the idea in urban metaphysics,
for instance, when
Joseph Reckford refers
to the rationalist Roman town as
a dream, when Aldo Rossi refers
to two perceived cities, the
real and the simultaneously
ideally imagined, when the
French sociologist Maurice
Hauriou refers to
the stabilizing power
of urban memory, and so on.
Lynch's second
theoretical model--
I'm going to have
to go on quickly,
because there's a lot of stuff.
Fall asleep if you need to.
Lynch's second
theoretical model,
the mechanical model
or the machine model,
covers a wide range of places
built for rapid construction,
often for colonial settlements,
be they for Egyptian
[? watery-side ?] workers,
Greek colonies where [INAUDIBLE]
links the colonial grid and
the needs of modern commerce,
Roman castramentation
and centuriation.
The Romans built 5,627
separate civic bodies
across the world's
vast empire largely
through a central
financing system
and a central spatial system
which encompassed both city
and country--
castramentation is towards
the form of the city,
centuriation is a
continuation into standard.
If you look at the area around
Imola in Italy, for instance,
you can still see these
Roman traces of squares,
each made by what an ox can do
in one day using a site chosen
by an [INAUDIBLE].
Roman centuriation or Roman--
[DOOR OPENING]
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know who you are.
AUDIENCE: Oh, Andrew Woodmore.
JULIAN BEINART: Andrew,
you've lost your hair.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it depends
on your [INAUDIBLE]..
It's good to see you.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIAN BEINART: And Andrew is
one of our numerous illustrious
graduates.
He did his PhD at
UCLA, and he just
published a book
with Sam Bass Warner,
which you should all have.
We go on to other examples
of the mechanical model--
the French Bastide towns
in the southwest of France,
and the enormous impact of
the Spanish laws of the Indies
on Latin American cities.
Spanish Latin
American cities are
founded on the rules of
the laws of the Indies.
And still today, have--
you take a-- it's not take.
In the United States,
the laws of the Indies
were pronounced from
St. Augustine in Florida
in 1565 to Los Angeles in 1781.
You take a town
like Albuquerque,
which is the subject
of one of our theses,
you will see it is
a hybrid town, mixed
using the rules of the
laws of the Indies.
One of the rules of the laws
of the Indies is interesting.
It refuses to allow--
it forbids Indians to
be allowed to enter
the stockade before the
Spanish cathedral is completed.
A perfect example of
architectural and urban
form serving a mixture of
blatant colonial, financial,
and missionary purposes.
It's not different,
very different,
from Edwin LaChance's use
of classical form in Delhi.
LaChance, after all, claimed
the Native Indians didn't
have any talent
at all, and if he
were asked to do a
capital in Australia,
he wondered whether he would
use the marsupial style.
We also briefly reviewed
on numerous examples
of the application of
machine ideas to city form,
be they as distant to each
other as Captain Chambless'
moving linear American city
and the brutally efficient
consignment of Africans
in Johannesburg
to the barren land
of Soweto using
one model of a horse as its
basis and repeating endlessly.
The organic model, the
third of Lynch's models,
focus on the
interpretation of nature
in some form or other as an
adequate lesson in the making
of city form at
some scalar another,
either as real or
synthetic landscape.
The other class focused
on a few theories,
none as significant as the
great Scottish biologist,
Patrick Gedde's--
whose work I've attempted
to follow as best I could--
whose writings and work
in Palestine and in India
introduced the
central application
of sensitive urban surgery, the
derivation of local culture,
the stable valley
section, and others.
I regard he and his son-in-laws
plan for the Hebrew University
in Jerusalem as one of the
great pieces of organic
architecture--
not biomorphism, which I hate,
and find silly, and elusive.
But the design for the Hebrew
University was much like MIT's.
It is a set of corridor
systems oriented
towards a single center.
You move from one discipline
through another to another,
much like you do or your
body seems to operate.
At the center, you have
a dome as the coverage.
The dome is not trivial.
The dome is a biological
version of what
all religions appreciate.
It's the architectural
synthesis for Arabs, Jews,
and Christians.
So this is, to me, a brilliant
and logical use of an idea.
He doesn't have to have
curved forms, like biomorphist
architectures do,
in order to satisfy
the deep structure of biology.
It's one of my
favorite buildings.
It's never built.
To examine the
relativity of nature,
we examine the USA's most
significant regional plan,
the TVA, and as many as
seven different [INAUDIBLE]
attributed to nature.
The pre-TVA, Southern
agrarian resistant to change.
Prior to '33, Roosevelt.
Henry Ford's view of nature's
embedded in agriculture.
His belief that American
industrialization,
such as Detroit,
without agriculture
was a threat to the
survival of this country,
the good survival
of this country.
He proposed buying from
Congress one of the dams
at Muscle Shoals in Alabama,
the southern end of the TVA,
and building a 75-mile
linear city combining
agriculture and industry.
His view of nature
was agricultural.
Roosevelt's vision of the
recuperative power of water
and green-- he used the term
water and green in 1933--
as beneficent to nature.
The locating of the anti-nature
war-oriented research
of Oak Ridge in the TVA caused
another reading of anti-nature.
The replacement of water supply,
energy by coal, and ensuring
coal ash disaster
in Kingston in 2008
caused The New York Times
to call this the greatest
environmental disaster
in America's history.
This is also in--
nature is both a
beauty and a beast.
We tend only to see
the beauty in nature.
Survival sees the beast as well.
Why did archaic people look up
to the stability of the stars
and the sun system?
Why is the God Ra in
Egypt a permanent sign
of heliocentricity?
Because it's stable.
If you don't understand
half the things that
happen to you when
you have to survive,
you look for stability.
Tenancy is a security.
Much though Hoover and Roosevelt
promoted taxation policies
for making homeownership
easy in the United States
and abjuring the
notion of rentership,
the argument was that a stable
world comes from a world which
owns land and property.
In the case of Diadema in Sao
Paulo, which I will talk about
at the end, you
will see the return
to this fundamental notion.
Really, in some ways, ideas
don't change that much.
They're just
reinterpreted differently.
Back to the TVA, the
victory of the snail
darter by environmentalists
taken to the Supreme Court,
and causing America
to pay more attention
to endangered species, was
the first great victory
for modern environmentalism
in this country.
Today, water supplies
only about 20%
of the energy
requirements in the TVA.
Nuclear energy and
coal supply the rest.
Another ecological perspective
on nature at the moment
is pressing the
contemporary TVA to use
appropriate sources of energy.
Tomorrow, for those of you--
you can see [? Kristen ?]
[? Zibert's ?] thesis on what
to do about the TVA today.
I only use the TVA as an
example of the often radically
different uses that
the idea of nature
has to supplement an
ideological position--
not an ideological-- perhaps
a scientifically ideological
position.
We spend two classes looking
at other theories of city form
other than Lynch's.
Wherever possible, the theory
was connected to an example.
So, for example, when we looked
at the apparently value-free
[INAUDIBLE]
agricultural production
map in Southern
Germany, we locate
it next to Gedde's
good valley section.
When we spoke of the
zone of transition
in the Chicago school concentric
circle model of a city,
we saw its zone of transition
as an important element
in the successful fulfillment
of the invasion succession model
in the American city.
The American city has been built
by invasion and succession.
And when Homer Hoyt ransacked
a model of the American city,
we mapped it against a plan
of apartheid Johannesburg
and Atlanta.
And when Manual Castells,
in one of his wilder days,
used the term with The Wild City
to apply to the American city,
we argued it in the light
of American consumerism.
We also looked at a
number of architects
who've made recent
propositions about the city
as theory, on the one hand,
and practice, on the other,
other than Lynch,
Alexander, [INAUDIBLE],,
and Martin, and [INAUDIBLE].
I want to get on to
the next section,
and the next section deals
with the 19th century.
In starting this
section of the class,
I argued that the 19th century
was the most important century
for you and urbanism.
The so-called
Industrial Revolution
was the biggest event
in human history.
Again, I dispute Muhammad, and
Christ, and all of these guys--
all of these gods--
and reply, the reality which
so fascinated Engels and Marx
in London and
Manchester was a reality
which was the most
inevitably transforming
of human civilization.
I think sometimes
this is possible,
because I studied the history of
modern architecture at Harvard
with Sigfried Giedion,
who discredited
the 19th century completely.
He used to come back
from weekends in Zurich
and say that he arrived on
Sunday and walked around Boston
and saw the horrible
furniture in the stores
in Boston's windows.
They weren't any
modern shops yet.
He was filled with energy
about the bad smell
of the ruling taste in
European 19th century design.
He said the only light
was the light sought
by the French painters
and by the good form
of the British Swiss
builders of bridges.
That the French painters
were interested in a wider
range of things
than Giedion didn't
illuminate his discourse.
So perhaps I'm a 19th
centuriest by exclusion.
The sudden advent of
modern industrialism
and its occurrence in England
has never been fully explained.
So we refer to a recent widely
published version of this,
the work of Greg Clark,
who argues, amongst others,
in studying wills
and other evidence,
that many, many
behaviors in the English
were transmitted throughout
their society which
led to the acceptance of
regular working hours,
less fighting,
and the acceptance
of other social norms suited
to the industrial process.
He argues this in a
kind of biogenetic model
and the transfer from the
wealthy, who lived longer,
to the poor, who lived shorter.
He doesn't exactly
say how it works,
but it's a very
controversial new version.
So, for instance,
cruelty to animals,
common in medieval games,
such as bearfighting
and cockfighting-- you'll
remember that Hemingway called
bullfighting the most
vestigial sport--
was forsworn.
And activities, such as
boxing, fought between dwarves
and giants to amuse medieval
crowds on Sunday or Saturday,
whichever day they chose,
was rationalized in 1850s
by rules of equal
weights and times.
More happened in
London between 1851--
the Crystal Palace, the
most significant building
of the 19th century--
and 1965 or '76 than
happened in history
in one city in its time.
I'll go through
London in a minute.
This industrial story
has had many tellings.
The denial of the
long-standing Malthusian trap
is one of the most significant.
You'll recall that the
Malthusian trap consists
of the equation, the
demographic equation,
that population can only grow
when there's a food supply.
And this has not
been possible until--
well, Malthus wrote in 1799.
He was still preoccupied by
the presence of the Malthusian.
The Malthusian trap was totally
destroyed by industrialism,
and cities began to grow.
So the denial of the
long-standing Malthusian trap,
the increases in
per capita income,
the massive
industrial-technological
advances, the
organization of labor,
the rise of
participatory democracy,
Engels in Manchester
watched, with Marx,
the rise of English democracy.
They were bored by it.
Engels' relationship to
the chartist movement
is interesting.
You see, they were
asking for too little.
Eventually, of course,
they were moved
to advocate revolution, which
they failed in 1848 in Paris.
And then subsequently,
Engels traipsed around Europe
selling a new dogma--
the elimination of
epidemic disease.
Jon Snow discovery three
years after the Crystal Palace
of the bacillus, which caused
the Thames to be a shit hole
and produce the
bacillus of cholera
in waves across
England, particularly
London, the Soho part of London,
John Snow's identification
of the bacillus led to
the immediate construction
of a bypass system to remove
garbage from the Thames.
The 400 million bricks
that Joseph Bazalgette used
to build, finish in 1865 of
the three east-west tunnels
and the two embankments--
one of the things
about cities is
that you perceive them through
your eyes, not your feet.
If you walk on the
Thames embankment,
do you realize that
it's one of Bazalgette's
last, final attempt
to capture sewage
before it reaches the river?
I shouldn't denounce the visual.
42% of the brain is occupied
with visual perception.
There are 10 to the
12 neurons, each
connected to 5,000
other cells which
equip us to see intelligently.
When Charles
[INAUDIBLE] and I worked
on the design of the brain in
the cognitive science center,
I learned a bit of this stuff.
And amazing business
that goes on,
if you've seen [INAUDIBLE]
research and how we see.
We don't see pictures.
We see billions of
pixels appearing
on the screen of
our eyes, and we
have to make sense of what
is static and what is moving,
what is new, what is not,
what happens to that.
All of this is coded into the
electrical system of the brain.
It is to make--
I can't remember who said it.
Maybe Leon Wieseltier--
I don't know.
Peter, you would know.
Seeing is not--
oh, I don't know.
Forgive me.
I don't know everything.
[LAUGHTER]
The evil side in the 19th
century was also on display.
Engels wrote about
Manchester's poverty
with aid of his illiterate Irish
worker mistress, Mary Burns.
Engels did something--
I mean, I'm sorry to
go on about Engels,
but the condition of the
working class in England
in your book written in your
20s is not a bad piece of legacy
to leave.
But what Engels did--
and I often compare
him to John Ruskin--
Engels walked in the city.
He tried to use his
body to pick up.
He asked his-- he would ask his
illiterate Irish worker friend,
why do they have no windows?
She'd give an answer.
He'd say, why do the main roads
not pass through the town,
through the slums?
She'd give him an answer.
John Ruskin, who
later in his life
after becoming the poet laureate
of England, wrote books like,
Unto This Last, for the
working class of England,
both combined a
social intelligence
with a physical intelligence--
not Raskin so much.
Raskin says he learned
to see by looking
through the window of
his childhood bedroom
and counting the bricks
on the building next door.
For somebody who wrote
the conditional-- at least
the first book on
English painting,
on English contemporary
painting, it's a lot.
Anyway, I'm losing my way.
I'm getting carried away.
I always do.
There's something in
my brain which suggests
stories rather than evidence.
[LAUGHTER]
Stories are always
much more fun to tell.
The extraordinary thing
about the British Industrial
Revolution, and why I'm so
fascinated by these tropes,
is that between Peterloo
in 1819 and Bloody Sunday
in Northern Ireland in 1972--
that's a 150-year period--
British troops nor police
killed no more than 11 citizens.
It's an extraordinary--
it transformed the world
at the cost of 11 people.
Oh, people died in
poverty and in childbirth.
I'll later tell you
the story of Ann Lee.
Who is Ann Lee?
Somebody in this class
must remember something.
Who is Ann Lee?
AUDIENCE: Shakers.
JULIAN BEINART: Yes.
Good.
There we go.
Ann Lee worked 10 hours
a day when she was a kid.
She gave birth to four--
no, not stillborn.
One was stillborn.
Three died in infancy.
She screamed out that
sexual intercourse
is the evil of the world.
She got onto a boat in
1774, and came to New York,
and started the anti-sex
movement called Shakerdom.
This is part of our
tradition of the transference
from physical--
not perversion-- physical
pain to social behavior.
The Enclosure Acts, the
violence of the Enclosure Acts,
removing independent agriculture
from the disenfranchised,
and the invention of
charity, British charity,
which never could,
and as it never can,
compensate for
the amassed wealth
that Marx started
calling capital.
I decided that the way to
respond to these conditions
was not as general
as this, but to look
at five cities and the
reaction to these conditions.
The first was London.
London was the world's large--
I'm watching my--
London is the world's largest
in 1850, and so on, and so on.
I've spoken of a
Joseph Basalgette.
The greatest stage that's
provided for the emerging
middle class, the first
subway ran from Paddington
to Finches Street in 1876,
making the first stage
in the world's best metropolitan
public transport system.
That, in part, enabled
London some 20 years later
to invest in automobile pricing.
Charles Booth made the first
map showing urban poverty,
and the effects of the invention
of the residential mortgage
system were an effect.
Paris, in contrast,
followed centuries
of royal preoccupation.
Distances in France is still
measured from the center.
Unlike London, again, Paris
kept building-- unlike London,
which had only--
the further west you go, the
less you need in Europe for--
the biggest walls start
appearing in Vienna and Cyprus.
London hardly had any
walls to contend with.
Paris kept on building walls
into the 19th century, often--
I won't make the relationship.
It's a tangentious one.
Paris reforming
largely due to 20 years
of a new form of
urban management
under the Prefect of the Seine,
who is allowed, after others
refused to engage in
the act, to engage
in a new form of
financing, namely,
borrowing capital to be
repaid on the increased
value of the improved city.
The idea of deficit spending
used here for the first time
has become current track
urban practice now.
It's national practice as well.
In fact, it separates
ideologies in this country
around the size of the debt
that we are allowed to carry.
Economists are only
right in one sense.
The other's all wrong.
For Haussmann, an
immutable budget
was never adequate to account
for the wealthy of the city.
It's a brilliant idea.
It's the idea that you see only
an idea of economic progress
and investment.
So in line with banks
also finding their way
in the new real estate, Paris
engaged in municipal loans
paid back only 60 years later.
Haussmann didn't invent
a plan for the city.
He's often accused of
inventing a plan for the city.
The idea of boulevards was
taken by Marie de Medici
from Raynaud's Renaissance
Florence, where
the old idea of
playing in streets
was part of the
construction of streets.
The etymology of the
word, the American word,
"mall," a place
where you go to shop,
comes from the
Italian words used
to describe the playing
of games in streets.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN] Is
that right, Antonio?
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
"to hit the ball."
Pall Mall in London
and the American mall
come from the idea of
playing in streets.
Maybe there's some
metaphysical relationship
between playing in streets
and shopping in a mall.
I don't know.
I never discovered it.
Haussmann didn't invent
a new plan for the city.
One existed-- the whole idea
of making a town like a forest.
Like a [INAUDIBLE] system,
it was very fundamental.
And there were competitions
in the 18th century for Paris,
and the famous one,
after the Revolution,
a commission of artist plan.
So Paris added boulevards,
avenues, trees, parks,
improved public transport
services, buildings,
extended street enclosure.
Haussmann, despite all
of the negative qualities
that he arouses in
architecture, at least
had and made an attempt
to adjust architecture
to urban situations.
He believed that the
city needed to look
and believed that
architecture could render it.
Since the individualism of
architecture is so rampant
and so few people
attempt, even today,
to create an architecture
based on an urban identity,
however, an identity is
created by great stars,
individualists like
Zaha Hadid, when
it comes to making
a plan for Istanbul,
does the most awful
inappropriate pieces
of nonsense.
So I'm more of a supporter
of Haussmann's thinking
perhaps more than his acts.
I disagree with Richard
Sennett on that score.
Bracketed between two
communal uprisings,
the [INAUDIBLE] to the
north remains unformed,
and it's not been helped much
by the recent international
competition for its reshaping.
We'll go onto Vienna.
Vienna's is largely
one of captivating
unused infrastructure,
the mess of wards
and [INAUDIBLE] surrounding
the city from Danube to Danube,
fortifications that barely
resisted the Muslim attacks
some 200 years before.
The world would
have been enormously
different had one day
not taken place in 1683
when the Muslims
almost captured Vienna.
Vienna had been dug
under, the walls,
and had it not been
the Catholic world--
it would have been impossible
to stop Islam had it not
been for the intervention
of the Polish King Sobieski,
with his armed troops
coming from the north.
The Muslims always attacked
the city from the south.
Christianity prevailed
over Islam in 1683,
and the walls and their removal
have always played a role
in the psyche of the city.
The renovations of the walls and
the [INAUDIBLE] took the form
of a long string of a street,
called the Ringstrassa,
with all kinds of non-religious,
liberal enterprises--
government, education,
music, culture, housing--
along its street.
This is a continuous system of
urbanism, much an elevated form
of the American strip.
It puts into question
two great theoriests--
well, not such a great
theorist, but a builder--
Otto Wagner, who conceived
of these plans for Vienna
as being modern.
There's an expandable
endless stretching
out looking outwards versus
Camillo Sitte, who's, I think,
wrongly described by
Schorske as an archaist.
He wasn't an archaist.
He was somebody who believed
in the limited experience
of human perception,
and therefore,
wanted the Ringstrassa
to be a set of monuments,
each associated with
an enclosed open space.
His idea for the ideal
piazza was an enclosure, not
a system of movement.
Barcelona-- the most common
approach to urban expansion,
to 19th century
urban expansion, took
the form of taking down
this old city walls
and expanding the
city horizontally
onto flat land where possible.
You have plans, like Antonelli's
plan for Torino, [INAUDIBLE]
plan for Bali.
In the Barcelona example,
you have the largest housing
development in Europe.
[INAUDIBLE],, an engineer,
returns to Barcelona,
but does extensive research
on the terrible conditions
in the old city first.
He even studies health
and nutrition, diet, age.
He enters a competition for
the city's expansion plan.
He wins it despite Trias'
neoclassical entry.
Cerds' plan is a set of
truncated 113 meter squared
blocks, each with
open green space,
stretching far beyond its
connection with the walless old
city, with avenues, such
like the Passeig de Grcia,
one of Europe's great streets
reaching to the village
of Grcia in the hills.
The Ensanche, as it's
called, is not so successful,
but it's been built at many
times the density and coverage
of Cerd by subsequent
city authorities.
Who was right?
Was the city right to grant
development privileges
to the subsequent builders,
both of height and density,
obliterating much
of the green space?
To what is the-- we don't know
how to measure these things.
Maybe Cerds' plan would have
been very boring at the density
that he proposed--
too much green space.
Would the Passeig de Grcia
be as great a street as it is
if it weren't as dense?
We're dumb.
In Barcelona, they can do
nothing else but cheer Cerd
as much as a hero as Guad.
There's a story, which I
haven't got time to tell,
which the Barcelonans
don't like,
and that is of Cerd
belonging to a socialist group
in Barcelona influenced by
a crazy French communalist,
called tienne Cabet, who
came to the United States with
a group of people, including
one of Cerd's colleagues,
and bought a piece of land
in New Orleans, almost died.
They moved northwards and
bought the town of Nouveau
in Illinois, which had been the
site of one of the Mormon treks
westward--
almost Stalinist plan of a town.
But God learn us, that it had
anything to do with Cerds.
Each of these city forms
that I've just discussed
produced a unique housing type.
It's another strange connection,
that if you do urbanism well,
you produce a good
version of shelter.
There is a residential
square in London,
the boulevard apartment
in Paris, the [INAUDIBLE]
and the Hof in Vienna.
I haven't got time to go into
the invention of Karl-Marx-Hof
in [INAUDIBLE] in 1927--
the reaction to the war
and the establishment
of Red Vienna building
communal environments even
before the Russians attempted
the social condensers
and [INAUDIBLE].
I'll just take a
detour with Chicago.
Chicago is one of the few cities
established in the 19th century
like Johannesburg.
The name of Chicago is
taken from the tribe
that lived there.
It means wild garlic
in whatever language.
The big idea of Chicago
was to link the Great
Lakes and the Mississippi.
Thus, providing a
continuous water system
from Europe to the east.
Well, that's before the canal,
the South American canal.
This never worked.
But in 1830, it established
the beginning of a market
for residential land,
which was endless.
In 1848, this was
amplified by the building
of the United States
cross-country railroad system.
125th of the world's railroads
crossed in Chicago in 1893.
This is in 50 years.
Chicago's notion of
breadths of politicians
is not associated with wind.
It's associated with hubris.
This is the most--
I don't know what the
adjective of hubris is.
This is the most hubrist city.
It's the capitalist model.
Hoyt described 100 years
of land values in Chicago
according to peaks and valleys
in a very cyclical model.
For every great
absolute mad investment
follows a depression.
Nothing fascinates me more
than the immense authority
of the private sector.
I think Frank Lloyd Wright
was fascinated by his clients,
or so the book about
his clients suggests.
People who had the
gumption to invent zippers
had the gumption
to buy his houses.
Everybody was in a mad
sense of invention.
The most extraordinary
story is the building
of 60 miles of illegal
subway at night
as if lying telephone cables.
The idea that you can build
the underneath of a city for 60
miles of illegal subway--
people were being killed on
the surface of the streets,
because there was
no traffic plan.
So the merchant class
decided to dig in the mud.
It's a mud city.
So the soft
underbelly of the city
can be excavated over time.
This was only
discovered in 1962,
when the thing started
flooding and nobody knew
where the floods
came from in Chicago,
because of an accident.
Now, Cronon's book,
Nature's Metropolis,
is a sardonic reference
to the use of anti-nature.
You can see I'm not
a lover of nature.
I'm afraid of nature.
It causes you to die.
[LAUGHTER]
I suppose I shouldn't say
that on my last class.
But 20 skyscrapers were
already built in 1893
by the time of the
Colombian exhibition, all
of these on sand.
Where is a less propitious
place to build a skyscraper
than in Chicago on mud?
And yet, they did it.
One of the lessons
from the private sector
investment in Chicago is
there was no attention.
There was a needless attention
to be paid to the public.
It's perhaps best
explained in the novel,
Devil in the White City, which
targets Holmes, the psychopath,
who took over a hotel
outside the grand ensemble
of the World's Fair and
started killing women.
There was no public authority
to supervise this man.
There was no police
force to investigate it.
Women just disappeared,
young women, who
came innocently to the fair.
Holmes was not eventually traced
for all his murders by Chicago.
He was traced by an insurance
consultant in Philadelphia
who couldn't explain
some of these deaths.
It's an enormous
disadvertisement
for a city which is built,
as some cities are today,
on the apparently creative
impulse of the private sector.
It's a dramatic economic system.
But it pays its
prices in other ways.
Chicago politics is--
I shouldn't talk about
Chicago politics.
I know nothing
about its history.
Burnham, the great manager
of the Chicago World's Fair,
proposed a plan in a
number of years afterwards.
His plan was to
build a six-mile arch
around the grid to centralize
the city to give it culture.
Some people have
taken on the idea
that it's important in
developing countries
to build a city
first to make money,
and then to invest the money
in upgrading its culture.
It's a sort of transformative
staged process.
It may have some merit.
In Chicago, the idea of Louis
Sullivan's grand auditorium
building with the most wonderful
toilets in the world attracting
people who walk through the
mud is an interesting kind
of combination.
I disagree with Mumford
and Sennett's view
of the capitalist
grid as commodity.
There was as much speculation
in Boston with its non-grid city
as there was in Chicago.
Reducing space to
a commodity is not
only a capitalist phenomenon.
It is an intriguing aspect
of the devaluation of land.
I'm going to have to speed up.
We've got a lot still to cover.
We took a look at panopticism
and the idea of the gays.
This was largely helped
by David Friedman's work
on the evolution of the
late medieval street,
from a street of work and
multiple invasions to a street
dedicated to image and control.
As examples, we
compared, in some detail,
the multi-monumental and
multi-use Nevsky Prospect
in St. Petersburg, and Hitler
and Albert Speers' proposed
central axis for Berlin.
We also took a brief
look at utopianism.
I must say, I suffer
from a disinterest
in utopian speculation.
I find it either like as
dull as science fiction,
and as absolutely devoid
of understanding of cities
as most science fiction is.
But we covered some
of the territory.
I was fascinated by Thomas
Moore's invention of the word
utopia.
It has both the prefix e-topia
and the prefix e-u-topia,
which mean different
things in Greek.
Who is our Greek friend?
One is good and one is what?
Nowhere.
AUDIENCE: Utopia?
[INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
One is good and one is nowhere.
So Thomas Moore's island,
1516 book, is about an island.
It's nowhere.
It has shared-- it is a
socialist republic, which
God learn us, how you
thought about it in 1516.
There's terminal
limits to the amount
of the houses you can occupy.
It reminds me of a
little-- oh, forget
about what it reminds me of.
[LAUGHTER]
We looked at a number
of other cases--
Pullman, Illinois,
Ann Lee and Shakerdom.
We also examined
three architects
with utopian propensities--
Le Corbusier and his endless
search for the right plan,
be it in 1922 for Paris
with a capitalist center,
later for Moscow
after the revolution
there was a syndicalist plan,
and later in frustration
because the citizens of Algiers
refused his many [INAUDIBLE]
plans.
He appealed for help to the
fascist Vichy government
and eventually to
Mussolini for help.
This is the strange
notion that--
it's not so strange if
you're an architect--
you find a solution which
emanates out of your soul.
It brings together
almost everything
that is creative about all.
All your juices are flowing.
It's the right one.
You examined 1,000, and
this is the right one.
Whoever is going to buy
the right one is OK.
Ideology doesn't matter.
Society doesn't matter.
Space is what matters.
This is what drove
Lynch crazy when
I had the only argument
I ever had with him
in this class, which we
jointly taught for two years,
about Aldo Rossi.
When I introduced Aldo
Rossi's book, The Architect
in the City, in this class,
Kevin writes about it,
in fact, his anger.
Sorry.
We looked at Frank Lloyd
Wright's tiny Broadacre City
as an evocation of
usonian democracy, which
used Henry George's
mantra of profit made
by development in the city
needing to be returned
to the public good.
We looked then briefly at
20th century resolutions.
We looked to Great Britain,
the New Towns expansion program
from the small towns of cities--
30,000.
By the way, there's
another curious phenomenon.
Plato's ideal size
for a city is 30,000.
Leonardo's is 30,000.
Ebenezer Howard, in 1910, later
within in London Garden City,
are 30,000.
Why?
It's demographic, I'm sure.
30,000 is probably
the amount of people
that you could, in
disease-prone society,
maintain a certain size.
Given the Malthusian
trap situation,
it probably works that way.
So the British built their
first new towns, likely
Corby and Harlow, at what size?
30,000.
They became tired
of 30,000 size.
Space-time suggested
larger size.
So mark two shifts to 50 to
100,000, the towns of Hook--
the best book on
New Town planning
studies, the book of Hook--
Runcorn, Cumbernauld,
and the mark three towns
of Milton Keynes, now 250,000.
Milton Keynes is a
postmodern attempt at a city,
mixed land use is using
performance dimensions instead
of zoning, a 1 kilometer by
1 kilometer space frame grids
to take maximum traffic loads.
The earlier towns had no
predictive mix and tight fit.
Cumbernauld Center was recently
voted the ugliest building
in England.
We looked at Russia
between 1918 and 1932.
We looked at the work
of urbanists looking
at the possibilities
of new urbanism
in the state which had
clients controlling
the means of production,
land use, and apparently
illuminated and
dedicated population.
Little gardens came from Marx.
A time of great experimentation,
the acronyms [INAUDIBLE],,
the invention of the essential
social condenser in housing
taken from the French
Fourier utopias.
I'm tempted to tell
this little story.
The Republican Party
in this country
was started in a town
called Ripon in Wisconsin.
Ripon was started by a
bunch of Fourier socialists.
The Ripon Society is still a
branch of the Republican Party.
I'm not explaining
the full transition.
I haven't got time, but
the overlapping of systems
is one thing that
keeps on intriguing me.
One of the great adventures
of contemporary urbanism
is its search for
overlappingness
and multi-purposeness,
as both an avenue
to deal with complexity
and the unknown future.
I'm just going to
skip a lot of this.
We look at the La Ville
[? Vale ?] competition,
a competition for tired workers
to escape from their daily work
routine.
And Melnikov-- the great genius
architect who invented the idea
of sleep enhancement so that
the Radio City Music Hall people
came running to Russia to see
whether they should put smells
in Rockefeller Center--
he allowed that wild animals
should patrol the streets.
Anyway, I'd like to go on
about the later reactions,
Khrushchev's 1956
edicts, and so on.
The next section dealt
with a question, what's
the relationship between--
is there any
significant relationship
between how a city
is made and its form?
Nine categories were
listed as possible methods
of city management and four
selected for close examination.
First of all, they're
relying on a super figure.
We examine the effects of
Robert Moses, the greatest
builder in American history,
on the form of New York.
We also took as a
case study the process
for the replacement of
the World Trade towers
and conjured how different it
would have been under Moses--
an interesting speculation.
We looked at the role of the
media, the media participation
system, S-O-M, and
Silverstein, on and so,
and a whole bunch of
things, and didn't
come to much of a conclusion.
The idea that a
single architect who
hadn't taken part in the
so-called competition
would be chosen as the final
client, final architect,
is an interesting resolution.
In reducing social
imbalances, we
discussed the idea
of advocacy planning
using the Cambridge and the
freeway connectors, our case
study.
Thirdly, will reviewed
the many notions
of changing people as a modality
to urban change, projects
such as potteries,
[INAUDIBLE] schools
without walls, [INAUDIBLE]
situations in Paris,
metro education in
Montreal, and so on.
OK, I'm going to jump things.
We're going to finish
a little after 2:00.
I thought there was too much
in 40 hours to condense to--
what do you do?
Maybe we can go on
for a few minutes.
Dealing with the difficult
question, the relationship
between social structure
and spatial structure,
I decided to review
the literature.
And it was too difficult to
isolate the relationship.
So I decided, as a professor
of pathology would do,
to take extreme cases
in order to learn
about this more trivial cases.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART:
Sure, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'm in an emergency as well.
[LAUGHTER]
So I invented the
notion of bipolarity,
where I could isolate
significant aspects of space
and society and see them
in some relationship.
We analyzed five
cities on this basis,
and I'm going to have to go
very quickly through these.
Jerusalem-- the
assembly of polarities
ranging from religion,
ethnicity, nationalism,
history, and others.
Jerusalem, by the
way, has never been
the capital of any country other
than the Crusaders and Israel.
So it's a rather
remarkable status.
To conjure up a
solution which was
shared equitably by all allowed
free access to religious sites
and performed as a capital
city for two nations,
despite problems securing
customs was attempted.
This is a difficult
piece of work.
We had to go through the
history from David onwards,
even dispute the
history of David
that the Jews give as opposed
to the Palestinian history
of David.
The idea of David
building a temple as
opposed to circulating the
ark amongst a nomadic people
was discussed.
Corbusier does a wonderful
drawing of the Jews
as nomadic people.
All of this came into our
vacation and understanding
of Jerusalem.
How successfully, I didn't know.
The world doesn't
have a solution
to the problems of Jerusalem.
Why should we?
We are an advanced
class in urbanism,
but we can't do magic.
After all, Jerusalem has
been going for 3,000 years.
It's gone through-- it's
been the most disabled city
in history, the most
destroyed, the most rebuilt.
It may well suffer as a cross
for the rest of the world.
It's an interesting
idea, that it's
destined to be a kind of
crucible of some kind.
In Johannesburg,
the second city,
we looked at the
spatial pattern.
We traced explicitly on
race, and with it, income.
We traced the city
through its first stages
to its absolute distinction
of race in 1948,
locating population
to the southwest,
and finally, and so on.
We also did a study of municipal
waste in the native township,
a black community
of 15,000 renters,
who were being removed
after 50 years to Soweto,
improve their housing
over the 50 years
with additions in a communal
language of wall decoration.
It's a study I did in
Johannesburg, which
was on the cover of three
architectural magazines
in September 1966.
We studied the 11 [INAUDIBLE]
cities on the 2000-mile border
between the US
and Mexico looking
at the polarities
of nationality,
and culture, and
so-called development.
We looked at El Paso,
Juarez, operating
as a single major
metropolitan area,
with each sector choosing
to maximize its options
on either side of the border.
We looked at colonial
Delhi and New Delhi
as sites of distance
between colonial and native
as polarities, the form
of the colonial settlement
conscious of difference,
chose amalgams
of nature architecture.
The bungalow, on the one
hand, is suitable for climate,
while using formal
facades to indicate
separateness and superiority--
the same phenomenon we found
in the laws of the Indies.
Similarly, the many
plans for New Delhi--
forget about [INAUDIBLE]
and New Delhi.
We did a short trip to the
dialectical relationship
between country and
city in Havana and Cuba.
After the revolution, Havana
was deemed a frustrated city,
while agricultural land,
such as the Picardura Valley,
it was deemed by
the state to be more
important in the national
consciousness and economy.
It's interesting.
Henry Ford, who is an arch
anti-communist and anti-Semite,
by the way, at the same time--
interesting that
you can be both--
argued for the same advancement
of agricultural form
in relation to industrial form.
Curious patterns
that emerge when
you go through this kind of
survey and look for these.
So it's not unusual that
Lenin Park outside Havana
places the major
recreational element
of the city on the
outskirts of the city,
much like [INAUDIBLE]
plan for Moscow.
If you compare [INAUDIBLE]
plan for Moscow,
one of the post-1918
plans, you can
see a similar configuration.
The last section of class--
and thank God we've got here--
looks at four models,
contemporary or recent four
models.
We first deal with the
modern movement's interest
in the form of cities.
The class follows
the discourse of CIAM
from La Sarraz in 1928
to Waterloo in 1960,
and the conception of the
city as a pristine assembly
of distinctly different parts,
as evidenced by Jose Sert's
book, Can Our City Survive,
for which Lewis Mumford refused
to write the forward.
So this notion of
the city refused
to admit any
knowledge of the past.
Rather, Corbusier tossed
out the traditional streets
in his books and replaced
it in his [INAUDIBLE] plan
with elevated highways.
It also refused the idea that
cities inevitably change.
Its source of learning
about the city
was not in response
to everyday life,
but to a technical adjustments,
such as extents minimums.
When [INAUDIBLE]---- forget
about [INAUDIBLE],, and so on.
One of the first reactions
to the urban conventions
of the modern movement is
a group of young European
architects, who [INAUDIBLE]
many [INAUDIBLE],,
advocating intense
interactionism--
[INAUDIBLE]
Smithson's doubling up
of streets in the Berlin
Hauptstadt competition
or the making
wide residential
corridors to resemble
continuous pedestrian streets
in Parkhill, Sheffield.
The urban world had to be
understood as a more complex
reality, seeking
merit in change,
both short-term and long-term,
and users playing a role
in the making environment,
a phenomenon they called,
the wonderful word,
"socio-plastics."
Perhaps we all engage
in socio-plastics.
We looked at a
number of attempts
to theorize about this period,
the [INAUDIBLE] adaptive
urbanism, strategy for
dealing with growth,
[INAUDIBLE] work at the
MIT on the MIT campus
extending itself systematically
with a kind of intricate DNA
of corridor with single-centered
staircases, facades, and so on.
We followed with
three case study--
the first of New University
plans from the orthodox Sussex
campus plan through
the universal 50 foot
by 50 foot by 13 foot
high Loughborough
model, the whole idea being
here that a university can
be predicted--
use can be predicted in
the USA by preventing--
by oversupplying
each regular item
with sufficient
energy and system
to allow it to change freely--
not a very sophisticated
idea, ultimately to the Free
University in Berlin, where the
designers predicted a future
form to be created by
the university users.
So this is the ultimate
dedication to the idea
that anybody can design
without any rules,
that, as Chomsky suggests we are
dedicated learners of language,
we are dedicated
learners of building.
It's a very current idea in
the work of Slum Dwellers
International, the great new
paradigm for the Third World.
We have-- I hope I've got time
to do a very brief case study
of Diadema with you at the end.
We looked at the idea of
temporary accommodation
in two cases.
The live-in Euro rotation
cycle of temporary exhibitions
in the center of Paris
from 1855 to 2000.
Almost every 11 years,
Paris was transformed
in its center in want the
playwright, [INAUDIBLE],,
calls a transvestite center
to a stone site city.
You can see Kevin
Lynch's interest
in time zoning in What
Time Is This Place?
That the city adjusts
at different rates,
that you build at
different rates,
that you associate
space with time in a--
I'm saying ritualistic manner,
not in the archaic ritualism
of Madurai.
This is the wrong class.
Sorry.
Hey, it's Alexander.
I couldn't see you that far.
I've got my glasses on.
Fine, then.
Come and sit here in front.
We're just about done.
We looked at the idea of
the role of temporariness
in cities, in major cities,
as I said, with the 1855
to 2000 cycle, changes
to the center of Paris.
Curiously enough,
this time-centeredness
is evident again in
the various attempts
to build these
temporary exhibitions.
The building across the Seine
looks like a wedding cake.
The Eiffel Tower is finally
allowed to be built,
because it looks temporary.
The Eiffel Tower remains as
the major producer of income
for Paris other than taxes.
The rest is disappeared.
So what looks to them temporary
is plaster and wood or metal,
and what is temporary
becomes permanent.
And the third case,
the second case,
is we follow the Olympic
games, which over a century
now has become a four-year
temporary visit to world
cities.
We looked at it from
1896 to London again.
London has had it three times.
We looked at St. Louis
in 1904, Paris in 1900,
the invention of the first
Olympic games housing
project in Los Angeles in
'32, the greatest games
of all in '32 in Los Angeles.
We looked at the
reciprocal version of it
in '36 in Berlin, all
seen as temporary.
Hitler, of course, didn't
understand temporariness.
He pulled down the glass.
He had the glass taken out of
the stadium which they used
and replaced with concrete.
Albert Speer designed a new
stadium for 400,000 people,
admitting that you
couldn't see anything,
but only admitting
that you'd have
to change the rules
of the Olympic games
in order to hold it there.
Hitler said, don't worry.
It's going to be--
in four years' time,
it's going to be
in Tokyo, and then
it's going to return to Berlin.
It won't be
temporary any longer.
It will be in Berlin forever.
Hitler was an
extraordinary urban mind.
He understand that to devise
the '36 games, at the time,
that the concentration camps
with Avery Brundage, the leader
of the Americans,
denounced this fact
by accusing America to be run by
The New York Times and by Jews.
What a fairly common ploy.
OK, we dealt with--
I'm sorry, we need
another five minute.
AUDIENCE: It's 2:00, though.
JULIAN BEINART: I know.
This is a special class.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, we looked at Aldo Rossi's
philosophy about permanence,
and Lon Krier's advertisement
for classicism is a timely
solution to urban development.
I became intrigued
by the two forms
of knowledge of the
past, history and memory,
at the conference I
chaired in Jerusalem.
Memory has a long association
with the physical environment.
Ruskin's memory is one of his
seven lamps of architecture.
The mnemonic was used in
architecture in Greek times.
People paraded in the book on
the magical palace of Matteo
Ricci, you learn to debate
by entering a house,
making your argument in the
center, going to the right
to make cause, going
back to the center
to reinforce your argument,
going up the stairs,
going to the left and the right.
We know very little about the
relationship between memory,
and architecture, and urbanism.
We know that about
Paradise Lost and Cain
calling his first city in the
Bible after his son, Enoch.
The great French sociologist,
Maurice Halbwachs,
and the power of
collective memory--
I haven't got time
to go into it--
one of my most
fascinating stories--
not stories-- a great theorist.
He wrote the book,
Collective Memory, and is
I think the single
most penetrating mind
about urban metaphysics in all.
That's saying a lot.
I didn't talk about
contemporary memory systems.
Robert Musso's claim
that nothing becomes
more invisible than a monument.
The Navy and Air Force,
which are-- the Air Force
Memorial in Washington, which
I had something to do with,
having the notion of updating a
system of keeping up with time.
I go into the apparent dichotomy
between public and private,
using a metrics of
user ownership, access,
meaning to demonstrate
the overlapping
between public and private.
I shall talk about
the private law
courts in the anonymous
states [INAUDIBLE]
in Boston and the federal court
building, which faces the sea,
and only McDonald's
faces the public city.
We then go on and on
about the American spirit,
the various agencies,
which contest--
I spend a few minutes
denouncing the new urbanism
as a solution to social
equity and to transportation.
I then, in the last class,
deal with the global South.
The statistics are alarming.
I just have time to
quote one or two.
Almost half the global
population lives on less than
$2.50 a day.
That is more than 3
billion people, almost all
in developing countries.
According to The World
Bank, the richest 20%
of the world's
population accounts
for 76% of all consumption,
while the bottom 40%
account for only 1.5%.
The world will have to build
1 city of 1 million people
every 5 days for
the next 42 years.
It predicts that
31 villagers will
arrive in an Indian city every
minute for the next 43 years--
700 million people in all.
Coupled with climate change,
40% of the world's population
lives on or near coastlines.
The combination of
poverty and climate change
is a drastic disaster
token for the next phase
of world urbanism.
I try to talk about the
Slum Dwellers International
paradigm of self-help
instead of governmental help.
I talk about the
lack of hope that we
have in world agreements.
I remember Woodrow
Wilson in Paris.
Woodrow Wilson in 1919
attracted the largest crowd
in the history of
Paris, because he
came to cement the
League of Nations
as an international
governing phenomenon.
We haven't, with Kyoto, a
miserable Kyoto in Copenhagen,
we haven't even reached a crowd.
I talk about microfinancing
and then talk about the success
of microenvironments.
Diadema, a slum 15
kilometers from Sao Paulo,
and its success, it's just
attracted its first shopping
center there-- the fifth
most violent homicide
rate in Brazil.
Education rates were pathetic.
Child birth rates
were off the charts.
It's now reversed
all of these indices.
It's used the Workers'
Party to stimulate trust
to find financing
mechanisms for new housing
for the subdivision of land
for the creation of tenure.
Trust and security
are what a writer
about microfinancing
from Thailand
suggests is what helps develop--
is one of the sources of
development for the future city
in the poverty world.
I'm sorry it's been so rushed.
I'm sorry that I have
to keep people outside,
but we've got a story to tell.
Thanks, again, for
all of you for coming.
I hope it hasn't
been boring listening
to what you heard 34 years ago.
I hope I've changed.
In the meantime, I've become
more arrogant and more angry
with large theories about things
without Lynch's attachment
to detail.
OK, thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]